Oh gasps me so you run one of the best
beach shows in the country this doesn't
sound like a bistro classic this sounds
like you cooking in your kitchen today
we don't want to do fish to cook you a
trick Theresa gimmick so you're going
you're up there under your I took your
time John Michell turned his back 10
years ago hi Donnie because he wanted to
become a little bit more rustic but
today he's going back to that fine
dining style and he's really pushed
about what he had for breakfast morning
I don't know it must have been a [ __ ]
strong pot of porridge I mean II hope
John Michell and sous-chef Yanni aren't
over stretching themselves winter fields
for red mullet please babe
Colleen give me a time please on the
first table one please a three-minute
sundae for fish these three minutes the
window baking on the other side of the
kitchen calling from Winningham fields
usually has the opposite problem
creating food that's just too fussy
colors havoc are exposed because they
haven't got their entourage of 25 chefs
and 15 gardeners and for you know
individuals to wash their cars so today
they are on their own tonight
Collins pan fine red mullet and
certainly with a bully based sauce and a
Mediterranean salad the whole idea about
this dish is that this is little asses
salad so each part has to be perfect and
that's what makes the dish it's not just
the flavors that you can show off you
make your sharp courgettes and green
beans so that's good okay how intricate
is it on a scale of 1 to 10 for the
garnish is going to be about 7 out of 10
the rest of it for wow it's not bad for
use it I know yeah Jesus listening
listening good deconstructing a Nicoise
salad in this way is a bold move now
he's got rid of all the distracting
frills Colin's gonna have to really
focus on flavors to make this work
I thought Colin I went to him Phil
doesn't go more complicated over the top
yeah he's reined it in he's he's gone
simpler it's a chance to concentrate and
really really show off over at Liguria
the timing of their polenta and deep
fried oyster
must be perfect i wonderful enter to
melt in your mouth winging it all this
flavor to disappear in your mouth it's
precise cooking
to take your place a little bit of water
there work together just try to drain
that fish next time in the clock when
you dry that fish a little bit like that
when you come to source it for source
filets and stick exactly that yeah great
watch the sauce on over the plates I
thought y'all as we played up the
pressure was clearly taking his toll
well he's the source of the plate like
these shaking hands of the Queen it's
going all over the place
he's a shame because he looks nervous
which I didn't expect
especially from a Frenchman so the rush
started shaking to be shaking my life
and even where they got money there was
no shaking enough really gonna make me
shake you like robots
hi it was ready wait move it I'll get
the oysters any stock lien happy
leadership that's absolutely beautiful
chef you're perfect in John Michelle's
hour of need I'm delighted to see that
sous-chef Yanni is stepping up to the
plate again I love the way you're
tasting as well yes yeah what you're
tasting yes is what they are eating yes
let's go go last table now please yeah
to John Dory away double three please
fish good to go alright good to go this
beers good to walk a school jean-michel
and Yanni are really working as a team
sending out plate after plate of
exquisite looking food Joe Michele they
look great fantastic
very nice go please no time to the plate
well then actually don't ever fall face
just good
and the dish from their guru thank you
poached John's Dory and langoustine cake
poster beignet on top and a lobster
bisque